we're going to see car smoke Automotive
heat zah zah and
zah oh
in the world where Landscapes
societies and beliefs within are vastly
different
Unity can be
[Music]
found Unity through a subculture where
passion forges the way with an
expression of heart
racing
uncompromising
Relentless
drive my reputation as a renowned
multiplatinum Grammy award-winning music
producer is a result of such drive and
runs par parallel to my passion for cars
now in hopes of expanding his worldview
and pushing his limits my son n say I
will set out on a journey to explore
different car cultures across the
globe to experience diverse communities
from all backgrounds exploring car clubs
the driver's stories and their
unbelievable Vehicles celebrating
Treasures built with the drive we have
in
common
[Music]
I